un amico di facebook oggi
mi ha scritto leggendo il titolo del mio
tocco di questa sera
fai una cosa visto che come la domanda
se è colpa dell'uomo il cambiamento
globale con il punto interrogativo fa
monta sul palco guardali di sì forte poi
saluta libreria entrerà nella storia dei
thread yo yo con inedito intendevo
qualcos'altro e utilizzo le cose che ci
ha raccontato simona mi è piaciuto molto
quell'ipotesi del braccio dentro e del
braccio fuori e partirei dalla prima
slide che voi vedete per stabilizzare un
attimo la conoscenza verso gli anni 80
la scienza si è incominciato a
preoccuparsi di un fenomeno e questo
fenomeno è un fenomeno di riscaldamento
del nostro pianeta e ha incominciato
quindi a studiare questo e si è
sviluppata una disciplina che non è
esattamente la scienza del clima ma è la
scienza del cambiamento climatico
poi ha subito per tutta una serie altri
motivi cambiamento nel nome ma possiamo
definirla così quale è l'obiettivo della
scelta di cambiamento climatico e capire
come cambia il clima quali sono i motivi
e quali scenari futuri ci possiamo
aspettare è una scienza
sì qualcuno dice che è una religione c'è
una profonda differenza tra scienza e
religione
popper ci aiuta in questa analisi è una
scienza se in qualche modo a delle
parametrizzazioni delle formule porto
dispiacere un professore che mi è molto
caro dicendo che secondo mesi
l'equazione del clima ed è un'equazione
abbastanza corta ne esistono tante ma
quella che viene definita un po
l'equazione di prima è un'equazione
abbastanza corta che dice che la
variazione di temperatura e quello che
voi vedete nel grafico e la variazione
temperatura nell'ultimo secolo
non prendiamo in considerazione quelle
precedenti se no siete già stanchi e poi
facciamo notte veramente e questa
equazione la differenza di temperatura è
legata a un parametro che si chiama
sensibilità climatica è un parametro sul
quale noi abbiamo ancora oggi nonostante
tutta una serie di misure abbiamo ancora
una forbice in realtà non abbiamo un
unico valore ma abbiamo una forbice
stiamo conducendo esperimenti stiamo
conducendo esperimenti mi raccomando per
capire come si comporta clima non stiamo
conducendo esperimenti su clima questo
togliamocelo dalla testa già successi
incidenti di fraintendimento su questa
frase questi esperimenti significano che
noi possiamo misurare o condurre
esperimenti numerici e la prima cosa che
noi facciamo è quella di andare
analizzare come diceva simona il il
braccio dentro quello collegato a cosa a
un ragionamento che è il più consolidato
il clima cambierebbe perché noi bruciamo
combustibili fossili questi combustibili
fossili si trasforma in in co2
le proprietà della co2 sono quelle di
intrappolare il calore nel sistema
terrestre questa è una teoria fisica
fisica chimica si può dire assolutamente
consolidata e forse perché così
consolidata diciamo che la più vasta
parte della comunità scientifica
aderisce a questa teoria
allora diceva hai una teoria
nella comunità scientifica aderisce
diciamo che si aderisce sicuramente al
processo fisico che è successo a questa
teoria ma rosa il perché io ora ben
definito la scienza in un suo scritto
che si chiama in questo scritto rumford
out uno spazio per il dubbio e dice che
la scienza è rappresentata da un momento
centrale che è eventualmente questo
consenso ma ha bisogno di spazio intorno
a questo momento centrale per poter
inserire nuova conoscenza questo
consenso oggi noi non interessa che sia
il 97 per cento che forse
propagandistico 82 per 174 questo
consenso sicuramente molto vasto quei
numeri cambiano perché sono state fatte
delle indagini le indagini su una base
statistica e voi sapete che la scelta
del campione fondamentale nell'ottenere
poi il numerino finale ma la maggior
parte della comunità scientifica
sicuramente aderisce questo cosa ci
porterebbe questa teoria quella che
vedete è l'aumento della co2 quindi
questo metodo della co2 sarebbe ben
collegato all'aumento di temperatura
questo però è un meccanismo di
corrispondenza di tipo indiziario il
vero la vera pistola fumante che noi ci
possiamo immaginare nell'esperimento di
capire se la co2 effettivamente che
produce quegli effetti è un
riscaldamento che noi dovremmo
verificare in una zona della alta
troposfera
abbiamo condotto esperimenti misure
abbiamo trovato dei risultati che
talvolta erano contrastanti
quest'anno sembra in un lavoro
pubblicato su una rivista di grande
prestigio che si sia trovato questo tipo
di indicatore quindi una teoria molto
omogenea che raccoglie un grande
consenso e che potrebbe finalmente
vedere l'effetto fondamentale verificato
per ora noi ragioniamo su questa teoria
con tutta una serie di altri fenomeni
che sono fenomeni ripeto molto omogenee
rispetto alla teoria ma che di fatto
sarebbero prove indiziarie da questo
punto di vista che sono appunto
l'aumento di temperatura
l'aumento del livello degli oceani
la fusione dei ghiacci la il cambiamento
del regime di precipitazione è un'altra
cosa molto importante per noi e perché
ormai la popolazione mondiale salva
raccogliendo all'interno delle città
la formazione delle famose l'aumento
della frequenza delle isole di calore
questa è il braccio dentro però come vi
dicevo nella scienza esiste sempre la
necessità di una dose di scetticismo per
poter andare a verificare che
effettivamente le ipotesi proposte siano
vere quindi cercare di falsificarle e
possiamo dire che gruppi di ricercatori
stanno per ogni singolo fenomeno anche
verificando ipotesi alternative per
esempio per quello che riguarda il
cambiamento del regime precipitativo e
questa aumento della frequenza delle
onde di calore si può ipotizzare
un fenomeno legato al cambiamento di
circolazione zonale sono fenomeni che si
ripetono oppure altri fenomeni che sono
legati a dei grandi fenomeni di di
oscillazioni delle atmosfere
oscillazioni su scale annuali su scale
multidecadal i che potrebbero
giustificare
diciamo che queste teorie antagoniste a
quella del riscaldamento globale
riguardano solo una piccola parte della
teoria del riscaldamento globale per
poter stendere il braccio fuori
completamente dovremmo trovare una
teoria che possa essere considerata in
parte alternativa questa teoria esiste
ed è una teoria che in libia
le nubi che sono un grande modulatore
del sistema climatico con i raggi
cosmici e con l'attività solare
la teoria viene attribuita svedese e i
raggi cosmici entrando nell'atmosfera
terrestre creano nuclei di condensazione
questi nuclei di condensazione formano
le in un di tipologia numerosità della
nube ha un effetto importantissimo a
livello superficiale e il sole farebbe
da modulatore l'attività solare le
macchie solari farebbero da modulatore e
quindi proteggerebbero in periodi di
alta attività la terra dall'ingresso dei
raggi cosmici mentre in periodi di bassa
attività questi penetrerebbe all'interno
del sistema terrestre generando questi
nuclei di condensazione quello che voi
vedete è la teoria e esistono delle
previsioni sui prossimi cicli solari
sono dovute alla valentina arcola e
anche lei ha pubblicato ovviamente su
riviste di prestigio quindi stiamo
parlando comunque di scienza e l'ipotesi
è quella che i prossimi cicli siano
caratterizzati da una bassa attività
solare
se sono caratterizzati da una bassa
attività solare si va quindi verso un
raffreddamento
il bello della teoria di questa teoria è
che si auto falsifica nel giro di poco
tempo ovvero questo tipo di previsione è
una previsione che dovrebbe incominciare
a dar luogo degli effetti a partire
praticamente dall'anno prossimo
durerebbe una trentina di anni 30 35
anni di raffreddamento e quindi si
preparerebbe il mondo
diciamo in una maniera molto diversa da
quella che stiamo percependo oggi
oggi stiamo percependo un mondo che è
costruito su questi scenari futuri e
quello che ci sentiamo in qualche modo
restituire che ci poniamo nel ramo nel
ramo più brutto di questi scenari si
parla di 11 anni e poi supereremo i tipi
in poi cioè punti di non ritorno
voi vedete in questa figura che riprendo
il concetto della sensibilità climatica
che è fondamentalmente quella forchetta
che vi dicevo
effetto moltiplicatore che porta a quei
cambiamenti di temperatura
se fosse vera questa teoria che non è
alternativa ma si può accompagnare a
quella del cambiamento climatico
noi ci potremmo trovare per un periodo
di tempo molto più lungo una generazione
una generazione e mezzo per poter fare
delle cose che finora non siamo riusciti
a fare
avete sentito parlare di batteria avete
sentito parlare di nuove tecnologie 35
anni sarebbero tanti quindi se si
verificassero tutte queste ipotesi noi
avremo una parte di riscaldamento
sicuramente dovuto all'azione dell'uomo
e quindi la risposta sarebbe sì
un'altra parte per ora di raffreddamento
dovuto al sistema naturale sia chiaro
che per esempio il panel internazionale
sui cambiamenti climatici tiene in
considerazione questa teoria questa
teoria però vede attribuito dalle chi si
sia appunto da questo panel un valore
molto basso per quello che riguarda la
probabilità noi abbiamo il problema di
poter ben definire questi valori di
probabilità di accadimento e si chiama
problema dell'attribuzione e se
l'attribuzione fosse bassa come detto
oggi allora praticamente non avremmo
effetti se questa attribuzione in
qualche modo la
la comunità scientifica la potesse
rivedere allora avremo più tempo a
disposizione avremmo messo insieme
ripeto il braccio dentro il braccio
fuori in un sistema che andrebbe in
riconciliazione dove le due componenti
principali quello di chi crede
prevalentemente al cambiamento climatico
dovuto all'uomo quello che crede
prevalentemente a quello naturale
potrebbero riconciliarsi non dico in un
punto di equilibrio perché quando
svensmark ha proposto la sua teoria ha
detto che molto probabilmente l'effetto
dei raggi cosmici poteva essere il 50
per cento degli effetti generali che
vediamo si è scatenato l'inferno quando
ha parlato del 50 per cento
però possiamo rivedere questi dati e
riconsiderare questa parte di teoria in
modo da poter pensare che il futuro sia
diverso io se mi permettete proprio
negli ultimi minuti visto che questo
argomento ormai un argomento che
interessa i giovani nel senso che il
futuro è loro per forza interessa i
giovani i giovani sono meravigliosi
vogliono cambiare il mondo
il mio suggerimento anche a seguito
delle parole dichiara che ha parlato di
formazione della scuola
io avrei da dire una cosa per cambiare
il mondo è un cocktail che ha tre
ingredienti e sempre questi tre
ingredienti che sono la responsabilità
la sobrietà e il sapere le cose
questo qui
ogni ogni generazione ogni generazione
mette quote diverse mete percentuali
diverse di questi tre ingredienti nel
cocktail che sarà venduto dalla prossima
generazione
la mia generazione probabilmente ha
sbagliato nella responsabilità perché
affrontato problemi complessi cercando
di dare risposte semplici per quanto
riguarda la sobrietà i nostri nonni
hanno cercato di dare la sopravvivenza
ai nostri genitori i nostri genitori
hanno dato la stabilità a noi e noi
forse abbiamo dato anche il superfluo
alle nuove generazioni per quanto
riguarda la conoscenza è un fatto
fondamentale perché senza la conoscenza
si rischia come la mia generazione ha in
realtà ha fatto si rischia di lanciare
degli slogan e noi siamo stati preda
dell'ideologia e invece la conoscenza un
fatto fondamentale quindi il mio
suggerimento per queste generazioni e di
fare quello che stanno facendo
sicuramente ma di ricordarsi di questi
tre ingredienti e ultima cosa
come per la cultura nel manhattan
aggiungete anche due gocce di speranza
che non fanno mai male
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]
[Musica]